[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren zu fällen nach 85 köpfen fünf
meinungen sie werden heute für die
leidenschaftliche debatten erleben unter
anderem sprechen wir über transgender
athleten in frauen wettkämpfen die
explodierenden preise die uns alle
betreffen und die forderung die andere
koalition aufzulösen was es damit auf
sich hat habe ich auch noch nicht ganz
verstehen aber bestimmt im laufe der
sendung meine gäste heute abend den co
vorsitz der linksfraktion im deutschen
bundestag dietmar bartsch der
fraktionsvorsitzende fdp
bundestagsfraktion christian dürr der
bestseller-autor dr dr reiner zitta man
ja sie haben richtig gehört er selbst
sogar zwei dokumentierte und last but
not least eine großartige kollegin die
bild sportmoderatorin valentina maceri
und die hat sich heute ganz fürchterlich
aufgeregt deswegen sie jetzt auch direkt
starten darf danke nina der familie
thomas hat ja in den usa eine hitzige
debatte ausgelöst dürfen transgender
frauen bei frauen wettbewerben
teilnehmen oder nicht und eine aussage
von jürgen lenders quer politischer
sprecher der fdp bundesfraktion heute
hat mich sehr wütend gemacht
ich glaube nicht dass trans personen per
se ein vorteil irgendwo dadurch haben
dass sie als anderes geschlecht mal auf
die welt gekommen sind
so dass die aussage kurz und knapp kann
man so definitiv nicht stehen lassen in
den usa wurde dieser hitzige debatte von
ex präsident donald trump losgelöst er
sagte das sei lächerlich und menschen
die mit männlichen geschlechtsmerkmalen
geboren wurden dürfen nicht an frauen
wettbewerben teilnehmen wir schauen mal
dieses lächerlich aus dem kontext sind
dass es an der stelle unangemessen
dennoch hat er recht männer oder
transgender athletinnen mit männlichen
geschlechtsmerkmalen haben frauen
gegenüber biologisch gesehen definitiv
einen vorteil und zwar wissenschaftlich
bewiesen 10 bis 20 prozent mehr
leistungsfähigkeit
valentina wir hören jetzt einmal rein
was einen transfer dazu zu sagen hat
denn wir alle am tisch können das ja
natürlich nicht nachvollziehen das team
möchte ich einmal gerne das statement
von caitlin jenner hören sie ist runs
frau und spitzensportler war sie und hat
gold in olympia errungen
ich habe von anfang an gesagt dass
menschen die biologisch gesehen männlich
sind nicht beim frauensport mitspielen
sollten wir müssen den frauen
sportschützen
jetzt haben wir hier zwei statements
einmal von einem parteikollegen von
ihnen vom herrn lenders der gesagt hat
es würde keinen unterschied machen frau
ist frau mannesmann ob jetzt um operiert
oder nicht und der ja sagt es ist
richtig dass man mit teilnimmt dann als
um operierte frau wir wählen sie das
denn hätte ja die hat die unterstellung
lautet ja dass alle frauen gleich und
alle männer gleich sind das sagt jürgen
lenders zu recht ist nicht der fall
sofort einig das behauptet donald trump
ist großer quatsch deswegen sage ich so
ähnlich wie es auch das ioc sagt man
muss gegebenenfalls auch differenzieren
aber diese pauschale aussage nach dem
motto wer als man ursprünglich geboren
ist der darf niemals dann im frauensport
in der transponder ist unterwegs sein
dass sie sich ausdrücklich für falsch
aus gesellschaftspolitischen gründen
nahe liegen auch aus sportlichen gründen
hat er verstehe ich allerdings muss man
ja da sagen ich verstehe diesen
inklusions gedanken man möchte natürlich
gegen die diskriminierung an kämpfen
aber in dem man in diesem fall gegen die
diskriminierung ankämpft schafft man ja
eine deutliche benachteiligung von
frauen und spitzenathletinnen die wochen
monate und teilweise für olympia sogar
jahre hat auf diese leistung hinarbeiten
ist an diesem tag abrufen müssen wenn
zeitplan aber athletinnen an diesem
wettbewerb teilnehmen die von stunde
null an zehn bis 20 prozent mehr
leistungsfähigkeit haben das ist unfair
für spitzenathleten wenn es so wäre also
wenn es immer grundsätzlich so ist wie
sie sagen muss man darüber reden aber so
ist es ja wahrscheinlich gar nicht
sondern deswegen bin ich da sehr bei dem
was das ioc sagt das internationale
olympische komitee die sagen ja lasst
uns die sportarten einzeln betrachten
wir wollen alle gemeinsam inklusion gibt
es glaube ich keine zwei meinungen auch
hier am tisch und deswegen sage ich
lasst uns jede sportart angucken das
muss jetzt auch passieren denn wir haben
glücklicherweise immer mehr menschen die
sagen ja ich fühle mich unwohl und ich
will mein leben leben was ich habe und
transgender menschen müssen dort
integriert ist kann nicht sein dass ein
verbot vom sport bekommen auch nicht vom
spitzensport wie viel prozent betrifft
darf transgender wenn sie sagen es
werden immer mehr also das ist mehr
werden das sehen wir uns im deutschen
bundestag wir haben bekennt transgender
im deutschen bundestag ra ganser zum
beispiel beispielsweise und da geht es
um die frage dass moderner wagen
namensrecht und solche dinge aber hier
ganz konkret sage ich weil es mehr
werden die sich die freiheit nehmen die
müssen eben auch die möglichkeit haben
am spitzensport hat dann eine lösung
entschuldigung wert in eine lösung für
transgender frauen eine eigene schiene
zu kreieren ich sag ihnen nur mal kurz
ein paar parameter damit sie das
verstehen den unterschied zwischen
körperlichen voraussetzungen man frau im
schnitt sind männer zwölf zentimeter
größer 10 bis 20 kilogramm schwerer
haben einen viel höheren muskelmasse
anteil viel größeres herz viel größere
lunge mit dann 50 prozent mehr volumen
ausdauersport springsport kraftsport
sowieso bei mehr muskelmasse das heißt
man kann das nicht gleich stellen darf
ich noch einmal einmal ganz kurz
widersprechen wenn ich mir die tat war
habe ich auch gleich übergeben der
könnte ja fast basketballer sei mit
seiner crew ist und ich bin jetzt nicht
so viel kleiner aber wir würden kollegen
einfallen ohne namen zu nennen lieber
die tabelle hängen bleiben die sind
einfach kleiner die werden mutmaßt sich
nicht basketballspieler sein ich will
damit nur deutlich sagen die
durchschnittswerte sind garantiert
richtig die sie genannt haben aber
dieses pauschale wird nicht
funktionieren ich habe noch kein
fertiges konzept heute aber das was da
gesagt wird mehr super kompliziert lasst
uns da mehr differenzieren aber in jedem
fall wäre es unfair wenn dicht von
vornherein zu sagen wie es donald trump
tut trans transgender menschen dürfen
nicht am spitzensport einsehen also ich
teile das ausdrücklich ich glaube eine
pauschalisierung hilft uns überhaupt
nicht weil frauen sind nicht alle gleich
auch trans denn das sind im übrigen
nicht alle gleich da gibt es große
unterschiede
aber sie haben völlig recht man kann
nicht ungleiche neue diskriminierung
schaffen indem man sagt das alles egal
deswegen sage ich wir müssen die
menschenrechtlichen dinge beachten
überhaupt die rechtliche dinge das ist
eine spannende herausforderung aber
bitte nicht mit neuen diskriminierung
deswegen ist so eine diskussion
der eine ist dass der andere ist völlig
falsch also ich glaube bei frauen bei
männern und auch bei trans länder gibt
es unterschiedliche sichten und man muss
die sportarten ich würde mal die these
wagen das natürlich bogenschießen dort
anders ist als gewichtheber ländchen
halt du warst die a nationalspielerin im
fußball für deutschland jetzt endlich
meine frage wie es denn eigentlich wäre
warum hast du nicht einfach bei den
männern gespielt also wenn ich mir das
jetzt so anhöre frauen sind
unterschiedlich männer sind
unterschiedlich hättest du auch bei den
männern starten können vielleicht was
wir doch noch bist du bist jetzt nicht
so groß nicht sagen da wie zum beispiel
aber bisher selbst gleich nicht trotzdem
da spielen können es ist ein sehr guter
punkt den die nada erwähnt also im
fußball hält sich das so ich habe immer
mit den jungs trainiert bis zur u17 auch
auf einer dfb eliteschule gewesen und
damit den jungs des ersten fc nürnberg
trainiert aber ich habe bei den frauen
gespielt generell im frauenfußball sagt
man kann man bis zur b-jugend ungefähr
mit den jungs mithalten danach wird
super schwierig also es ist nahezu
unmöglich mache ihm ein beispiel das
diesen leistungsunterschied zeigt zu
meiner zeit als ich in der 15
nationalmannschaft gespielt habe hat
unsere frauen nationalmannschaft ein
testspiel gehabt gegen die u15 des vfb
stuttgart jungs wissen sie wie das spiel
ausgegangen ist
zweistellig für den vfb stuttgart das
waren 15 jährige jungs das war für uns
damals einfach unmöglich von der
geschwindigkeit und von der
körperlichkeit mitzuhalten taktisch
technisch kein problem aber sobald um
die physis geht können wir frauen mit
männern nicht mithalten da sieht man ja
auch eins dran heute gibt es doch die
modische these geschlecht ist eigentlich
nur ein sozial konstrukt sozusagen
biologisch gibt es gar nicht das ist
irgendwie ein konstrukt ja und das ist
halt einfach diese these ja weil wenn
das so wäre ja schlimm wenn das so wäre
wenn das sind wenn das so wäre nur ein
konstrukt ja dann dürft es ja gar keine
unterteilung in männern frauen game
sondern dürft ihr eigentlich eine
mannschaft für alle geben wenn du etwas
ist was ich mir im kopf irgendwie
ausgedacht haben sie haben doch in
vielen sportarten die situation also ich
habe mich basketball volleyball gespielt
und das durchaus einigermaßen
erfolgreich aber es gibt eine
unterschiedliche netz höhe zwischen
frauen und männern aus gutem grund gutem
grund oder wir haben damals auch dann
selbst auch gegen clubs gespielt und so
weiter das ist ein unterschied
selbstverständlich deswegen kann unter
umständen frauen volleyball attraktiver
sein als männer wollen aber das ist eine
geschmacks war im fussball übrigens
ähnlich also ich glaube schon dass wir
dort differenzieren müssen in den
sportarten das wäre wirklich verheerend
jetzt alle in einer kategorie starten zu
lassen und hier ist endlich gott sei
dank dieses in anführungsstrichen
problem diese herausforderung erkannt da
muss sich der sport darum kümmern da
müssen wir uns auch darum kümmern aber
bitte nicht mit einer scheinbaren
abschaffung einer diskriminierung viele
neue schaffen das wäre meines erachtens
nicht in ordnung also trotzdem würd mich
interessieren sie haben gefragt
wir diskutieren hofft so oft über
transgender diese probleme wie viel
prozent unter spitzensportlern wie viele
betrifft ist jetzt gibt es darüber eine
verlässliche zahl sind es 0,1 prozent
oder 0,2 prozent oder über was
diskutieren wir hier genau ich weiß es
ich frag einfach wissen es ist echt ich
kann keine genaue zahl nennen aber es
ist ja ein super komplexes thema weil
logischerweise und deswegen wollte ich
auch unbedingt dieses wort lächerlich
von donald trump streichen gibt es
transgender athleten oder athleten
nennen sagen was man so die einen recht
natürlich an wettbewerbsfähigkeit haben
und dass man sich durchaus die frage ist
nur dann wie schafft man für die einen
fairen wettbewerb der dann für die
frauen genauso fair ist übrigens gibt es
die gleiche frage anders rum denn es
gibt ja sportarten in denen frauen
männern voraus sind dann wenn es um
beweglichkeit beispielsweise geht
rhythmische sportgymnastik etc da
wiederum haben frauen aufgrund ihrer
genetik und ihren biologischen anlagen
männern gegenüber vorteile es ist eher
so dass einzelne dinge immer zum maßstab
genommen da wird eine frau ex-mann
olympiasiegerin über 800 meter und dann
wird das war ja mein mann das geht nicht
das müssen wir neu behandeln so wir
wissen das und ich glaube dass da das
boc und alle mitgliedsländer auch
gefördert gefordert sind und wir im
übrigen auch also es muss auch in
deutschland und überall geklärt werden
und vor allen dingen wahrscheinlich auch
nach altersgruppen das ist ja wohl noch
etwas anders sammer ist etwas anderes in
den jüngeren jahren als bei älteren also
ich glaube es eine richtige
herausforderung die nicht einfach
überwältigend aber diese entscheidung
sind ja schon getroffen worden es gibt
ja bei den sportarten wie zb 15 und 16
männlich weiblich und erfolg haben auch
neue entscheidung wir müssen neue
entscheidungen treffen weil ich glaube
dass wir mit dem bisherigen wir können
nicht einfach sagen das ist also im
trump schon sinn jetzt ohne lächerlich
das geht meines erachtens nicht aber ich
glaube da hat niemand in der politik im
moment eine lösung aber wir müssen die
herausforderung annehmen aber da sind
die sportverbände als erstes gefragt die
müssen vorschläge machen ich bin ganz
sicher dass einzelne sportverbände
vorreiter sein werden und sagen so
machen wir das und dann wird das
gesellschaftlich anerkannte derzeit im
gegensatz zu valentina finden sie beide
das ich glaube fdp und die linke war
selten so nah wie heute abend
ist das muss jetzt und fdp das selbe
arbeit die frage die ich jetzt natürlich
stelle ist also in diesem konkreten fall
wenn wir noch mal auf diesen fall hier
thomas zurückkommen sind sie beiden also
eigentlich der ansicht dass man sie
nicht hätte ausschließen dürfen dann von
den frauen wettkampf
also ich glaube wir sind beide auf dem
eis unterwegs war offen gestanden dass
ich bin kein sportmediziner weil die
müssen auch noch mal gehört werden an
der stelle also was da muss mehr
fachlichkeit rein in die debatte ich
glaube nur wichtigen das war mein
wirklich hoch geschätzten kollegen
jürgen lenders wichtig eins zu sagen wir
können nicht einfach sagen weil jemand
transgender ist mustafa osso
ausgeschlossen werden donald trump messi
und wenn wir uns da einig sind haben wir
glaub ich eine einflugschneise und eine
aufgabe genommen und diesen konkreten
fall ich glaube nicht verdienen bewegen
sollte man nicht aus deutschland
bewerten also das ist glaube ich dann
ohne form von arroganz zu sagen das darf
nicht sein dass darf sein in den usa ist
diese diskussion die etwas angeregt und
auch ein bisschen schlussfolgerung die
dann verallgemeinerung würdig sind
gezogen wenn das glaube ich die aufgabe
können wir dann darf es halten sie
würden sagen donald trump aussage geht
gar nicht aber sie würden auch zustimmen
wenn ich sage es ist den frauen
gegenüber unfair den spitzenathletinnen
ich würde sagen wir brauchen die
diskussionen müssen wirklich die
sportarten betrachten ja es ist ja das
ist ja dass der herausforderung von
politikern es ist meistens komplexer und
differenzierter und das ist unser job
dann auch solche antworten zu finden und
da bin ich bei dietmar bartsch die
sportverbände sind da gefordert ich
glaube zu mehr wollen sich die herren
mich hinreißen lassen valentina das ist
zwar schade aber auch in ordnung und wir
machen weiter mit der these von ihnen
herr waltz ja wir haben aktuell in
deutschland für viele menschen ein
riesiges problem das sind die
dramatischen preissteigerungen viele
menschen können das was zum leben
notwendig ist aktuell nicht mehr
bezahlen heute hat die koalition ein
entlastungspaket beschlossen ja da ist
einiges vernünftiges dabei aber ich sage
im kern ist das ein entlastungspaket
andere länder haben entschlossen
gehandelt und ich sage auf der hand
liegt dass man wirklich bei
grundnahrungsmitteln bei
grundnahrungsmitteln die mehrwertsteuer
senkt der staat hat im vergleich zum
vorjahresquartal 18,8 milliarden mehr
eingenommen das muss den bürgerinnen und
bürgern zurückgegeben werden ich stehe
auch für andere möglichkeiten offen aber
die mehrwertsteuersenkung wäre das
schnellste wenn natürlich eine
staatliche aufsicht da ist die auch
dafür sorgt dass die preise bei den
verbraucherinnen und verbrauchern
ankommen wir haben die situation dass
bei dem entlastungs päckchen rentnerin
und rannten dann nur sehr eingeschränkt
sehr sehr eingeschränkt betroffen sind
also viele fallen durch zum beispiel bei
den energiekosten und wir haben eine
situation dass in dieser lage die
kinderarmut steigt hier muss staatlich
entschlossen gehandelt werden das was
jetzt passiert ist ist zu wenig
inflationsrate bei sieben prozent
rentner bekommen kaum etwas ampel ist
gefordert das heutige kann maximalen
stadt gewesen sein
sie werden ja eigentlich angesprochen ja
herzlichen dank dass ist dagegen halten
dann die meinung zu haben und auch die
gegen die gegnerische meinung sozusagen
von meiner seite zu höheren
grundfreibetrag erhöht aber die mama
pauschbetrag erhöhte pendlerpauschale
erhöht wir werden etwas einführen bei
benzin steuern dass wir das reduzieren
direkt eine tankstelle volumen plus die
sozialleistung die wir geben mich
beispielsweise heizkostenzuschuss dem er
noch mal verdoppelt haben mir geht es
nicht darum lobby in einen zusammen weil
herr barth stadt und ein punkt recht das
kommt jetzt gerade bei den menschen in
deutschland an nur gerade bei den
kleinen und mittleren einkommen die es
schwer haben ich habe das nur auf
gezählt weil das türmt sich insgesamt
auf eine summe von 30 milliarden euro
entlastungspaket das ist tatsächlich
historisch hat zu große zeiten und davor
auch nie gegeben dass diese regierung
tut etwas und jetzt sagt herbert da
müsste noch einmal oben drauf ich habe
jetzt eine sache vergessen das darf ich
sagen all die dinge die ich steuerlich
aufgezählt haben werden wir rückwirkend
zum ersten januar diesen jahres machen
auch das hat es noch nicht gegeben herr
barth sagt die mehrwertsteuer da
antworte ich für grundnahrungsmittel
grundnahrungsmittel da antworte ich da
haben wir während der korona pandemie
eine sehr schlechte erfahrung gemacht
sie sagen ja eine vorübergehende
mehrwertsteuersenkung das hat die gruppe
ja schon mal gemacht während corona und
ich habe immer gesagt das ist eine
amazon- corona hilfe steuer gewesen das
hat nämlich den menschen nicht wirklich
was gebracht weil die garantie dass
damit die preise senken die kann der
staat nicht geben und wir haben ein
besonderes problem wir reden von
hunderttausenden von produkten in der
sozialen marktwirtschaft wird es der
staat nicht schaffen das zu monitoren
auch die steuersenkung die hadsch möchte
wirklich dann auch an der ladenkasse
ankommt deswegen ein nein von meiner
seite zu einer vorübergehenden
mehrwertsteuersenkung und im jahr gibt
es im bundestag von mir zu dem was die
gröger dass die ampel koalition hier
macht also bei einigen maßnahmen die die
haben wir beschlossen hat bin ich ja
überhaupt nicht dagegen also eeg-umlage
abschaffung jetzt richtig heiß ist ja
ich wollte wo ich andere sondern war
auch zu loben wenn etwas lobenswertes da
ist nur eins bleibt all diese maßnahmen
sind bei einer inflation von 7,3 prozent
und ich erwähne jetzt mal zwei andere
gruppen die rentnerinnen und rentner die
bekommen eben auf dem energiesektor
nichts nichts die rentner sind nur sehr
eingeschränkt betroffen da kann man
jetzt sagen da hat herr heil gesagt ja
aber wir haben die höchste
rentenerhöhung in der geschichte der
bundesrepublik west ja sie ist noch
niedriger als die inflationsrate
oder nehmen sie die kinder bei kindern
und das sind ja gerade alleinerziehende
die die wenig haben da kommt von diesem
paket objektiv wenig an und deswegen
sage ich bei grundnahrungsmitteln
da kann es helfen denn sie haben recht
ansonsten mehrwertsteuersenkung ich habe
das damals auch porsche rabatt aber noch
weiter in der opposition haben wir
schwer kritisiert genannt da ist ja
etwas dran weil das für die natürlich
viel mehr ist deshalb wirklich
eingeschränkt aber generell meine these
ist wir haben jetzt durch den ukraine
krieg natürlich durch all die dinge die
jetzt mit lieferung zu tun haben vor
shanghai die schiffe und so weiter
lieferketten sind unterbrochen
riesenprobleme ich will das überhaupt
nicht kleinreden das ist auch nicht die
verantwortung der neuen ampel regierung
aber diese explodierenden preise die
hatten wir so noch nicht und das ist
nicht das ende der fahnenstange
deswegen ist das jetzige wirklich nicht
ausreichend insbesondere für diejenigen
mit kleinen einkommen und darum jetzt
die große differenz auch zu machen das
ist ein punkt ich sage aber auch wir
müssen mal bei den unternehmen die jetzt
wahnsinnig profit gemacht haben uns
extra profite dann müssen wir vielleicht
auch den mut haben etwas abzuholen wir
müssen auch vielleicht bei denjenigen
die über wahnsinns vermögen verfügen
sagen dieser situation muss dafür die
für die des monats 120 das gute idee
befragten einfach mal jemand ich hoffe
ich darf das hier sagen herr doktor
doktor sollte man sie haben ja ein
wahnsinns vermögen also wollen sie jetzt
nicht einfach etwas abgeben heraus sagt
der staat soll zu ihm kommen und ein
paar millionen abzweigen wie sehen sie
ja an meinem haar million abzweigen
könnte und es passiert nichts dann ja
alles ist ja auch keine neue these das
ist ja egal was auf der welt passiert
ihre lösung ist dann immer die
millionäre die sollen jetzt bezahlen und
damit seien alle probleme der welt
gelöst aber so ist es halt nicht also
wenn sie sagen mehrwertsteuersenkung da
bin ich dafür ich bin immer für jede
steuersenkung grundsätzlich jeder arzt
also da haben sie mich immer als
anhänger aber man muss ja mal gucken was
sind die ursachen eine inflation ja sie
haben ja ein paar dinge genannt jetzt
aktuell ukraine kriegt man könnte auch
sagen die verfehlte energiepolitik die
wir das über jahre gehabt habe aber es
gibt ein hauptgrund und das ist die
politik der zentralbanken seit jahren ja
dass die gelddruckmaschinen angeworfen
worden sind dass die zinsen auf null
gesenkt worden sind dass anleihekäufe
sind das ist der eigentliche grund und
da können wir machen was wir wollen das
ist so ähnlich wie wenn sie zum zahnarzt
gehen und sagen ja wir haben
zahnschmerzen er sagt jetzt eine
schmerztablette wie kannst du nehmen
aber das sieht man sie eigentlich da
sind die zahnschmerzen natürlichen
strecke in dem moment ja und das und ja
vorübergehend und das problem ist nur
dass muss man ehrlicherweise sagen dass
die politik das nicht direkt
beeinflussen kann weil die zentralbanken
sollen unabhängig sein und die
zentralbanken sind aber die hauptursache
also die ezb in europa und die fed in
den vereinigten staaten die die
verantwortlich sind durch ihre politik
für die inflations wege hat auch die
politik leider muss man sagen nur im
beschränkten einfluss grad und ich gebe
rechtsschutz erst der anfang das kann
auch noch wenig schlimmer kommen will
man denn dann immer mehr immer mehr
staatliche hilfen dass das das geht
nicht also ich darf einmal noch mal
wieder sprechen also zunächst mal wenn
sie sagen jawohl ich bin dafür dass wir
in dem bereich wo wirklich menschen kaum
das monatsende erreichen etwas tun
müssen und das betrifft inzwischen mehr
dass wir dort auch über maßnahmen
mehrwertsteuersenkung auf
grundnahrungsmittel ist ein punkt
direkte hilfen werden total wichtig und
richtig würde ich präferieren aber ich
will eins noch sagen weil sie sagen
jetzt hilft es immer dieselbe these ich
will mal 1 festhalten in der pandemie im
letzten jahr haben die zehn reichsten
deutschen die zehn reichsten nur die
zehn reichsten einen vermögenszuwachs
von 100 milliarden da sind sie nicht
dabei traurig ich bin auch nicht dabei
auch traurig und wem hat das problem es
geht doch überhaupt nicht darum zu
schaden es ist doch geht doch nicht
darum zu schaden aber nicht den mut zu
haben wir einen kleinen teil hat ein
kind erwartet es schadet denjenigen die
wenig haben ich plädiere
haben sie wenn jemand der jüngste
milliardär ist aus deutschland der hat
2,2 milliarden mit 21 jahren da ist im
system etwas schräg in einer feuchten
stoff würde also freue mich darüber
nicht weil es dann eine falsche
erbschaftssteuer gibt weil es dann eine
es ist nicht es ist niemandem
vermittelbar wenn sie kinder haben die
am monatsende nicht satt werden und auf
der anderen seite jemand mit 22
mehrfacher milliardär ist dann ist im
lande etwas faul
wir müssen mal ein bisschen sortier also
ein bisschen sortieren von was reden wir
dann reden wir von geld auf der auf dem
sparbuch nein das reden wir natürlich
nicht das ist investiertes vermögen von
dem herbert spricht da sind maschinen
hein das sind anlagen das in joe's legen
wird mache ich ein vorwurf an die
linkspartei es gibt ja auch andere
parteien im deutschen bundestag die
immer mal wieder die idee haben so
genannte substanz steuern einzuführen
das wort muss ich mal kurz in die runde
werfen das heißt nicht aus dem was ich
erwirtschafte gebe ich dem staat
richtigerweise was ab sondern aus dem
was ich bereits habe sozusagen was er
per se kein gewinn abwirft die steuern
die herr bartsch vor schlicht würden
auch unternehmen zahlen die in dem jahr
verluste machen die würden diejenigen
zahlen die groß sind gegebenenfalls auch
mittelständler aber die würde nichts
anderes machen als stopps abbauen müssen
denn gerade bei der erbschaftsteuer und
jetzt erheblich anheben würde ein junger
firmenerbe und es geht mir gar nicht
darum ob ich dem das können oder nicht
aber ich will dass der die jobs erhält
das ist doch mein punkt das ist lohn und
brot und arbeit viele millionen menschen
in deutschland gerade mittelständischen
bereich das heißt all die vorschläge
dieser substanz steuern die gehen an die
substanz des deutschen mittelstandes und
kosten und jobs das heißt dass
produziert invite armut ich war gerade
steckt eine bestimmte vorstellung
dahinter also bei ihnen steckte man die
vorstellung dahinter der arme der ist
nur arm weil der reiche reicher das
kennen sie hat das gedicht von brechts
bestimmt aber mit reicher mann standen
da und sagen sich an und der arme sagte
bleischweren staaten wärst du nicht
reich und bekenntnissen und das ist das
ist einfach unsinn ja und ich kann auch
erklären warum gucken sie mal zum
beispiel im jahr 2000 da war es doch so
da gab es 500 milliarden auf der welt
heute gibt es fünf mal so viele
milliardäre gleichzeitig ist die zahl
der armen auf der ganzen welt von 24
prozent im jahr 2000 auf unter zehn
prozent gesunken das heißt wenn diese
logik stimmen würde von dem gedicht von
berthold recht was auch ihre logik ist
ja da könnte man das ja gar nicht
erklären das ist der grund ihr kennt
sich wachstum reguliert dass es wachsen
dass ich erklären dass georg erstmal
will ich als ein richtiger sprechen weil
also dass sie vertreten die these die
linke will die substanz besteuern und
unternehmen kaputt machen und
arbeitslosigkeit also wir sind wir nicht
behämmert also werden wir dann langsam
werden die substanz versteuert habe ich
noch niemals gesagt also auch bei einer
vermögenssteuer im übrigen gibt es eine
private das ist ja übrigens das problem
weshalb hat das verfassungsgericht das
96 aufgehoben weil diese trennung etwas
schwierig ist aber darum geht es nicht
wir haben in deutschland sechs millionen
geldvermögen allein das ist ja das
spannende also da ist ja schon mal eine
frage ob ihr und ich wiederhole noch mal
niemand kann mir erklären übrigens die
2,2 milliarden des jüngsten milliardärs
der welt die sind nicht nur in anlagen
das ja einfach nicht wahr dass da sage
ich ganz klar wir müssen regeln
der mit 21 jahren sind der reichste der
welt können sie doch nachlesen ich bin
ja da ganz der heißt lehmann übrigens
ist so ein netter nahm und das hilft und
nicht so sonderlich weiter aber das ist
jetzt nicht der punkt ist ich kenne den
gar nicht wahrscheinlich netter mensch
wahrscheinlich wird der ganze darum
gehen zunächst westgate für mehr
beschäftigt anstatt der erleben das ist
ja welcher sich vor allem menschen es
ist super dass ich fühle mich ein
beispiel
wissen sie wir haben in deutschland
leider und niemand am tisch wird sagen
dass das gut ist eine steigerung bei der
quote der kinderarmut alle sind dagegen
ja ich weiß das rad mit sich ich habe
also auch dort mit fdp kolleginnen
früher an diesem thema da muss was
passieren
kindergrundsicherung was im
koalitionsvertrag steht wo ich gesagt
hat lobe ich ausdrücklich da ist auch in
diesem haushaltsjahr nicht ein cent ich
bin sehr gespannt ob das kommt warum
passiert nicht da viel schneller und was
diese riesen vermögen betrifft nochmal
ich bin für ausgleich wer vermögen sich
erarbeitet wer etwas leistet nur zu aber
diese wahnsinnigen das meiste vermögen
in deutschland wird vererbt und nicht
erarbeitet und mai doch sein kann ich
kann ich ihm gleich es gab neuerlichen
untersuchung da ging es eigentlich ein
anderes thema vom dgb ganz unverdächtig
dagegen sehr eigenen strom um den
zusammenhang von
persönlichkeitsmerkmalen und millionären
und da haben die zu gleichen stichprobe
gemacht wie viel waren der erben und
wieviel waren der selfmade leute dann
waren einige wo ich sagen konnte wenn
man dir ausrechnet waren 79 prozent
waren selfmade und 21 prozent waren sie
als wohlhabender sagen diese studie die
ich auch sogar kenne und das sind
diejenigen die pur geerbt haben
diejenigen die natürlich ein erbe
bekommen und das aussehen sind sofort
selfmade also das ist eine interessante
studie ich habe das gelesen sogar weil
ich mir genau auch diese zahl
aufgefallen meine these und die bei der
bleibe ich auch da haben wir gott sei
dank unterschiedliche sichten ich sage
wir müssen dort für ausgleich sorgen wir
müssen für chancengleichheit bei den
heranwachsenden und deswegen natürlich
kann man die these vertreten also jede
steuer also ist eine zu viel steuer ist
auch die vertrete ich ausdrücklich nicht
der staat hat aufgaben realisieren muss
und eine dieser aufgaben ist dafür zu
sorgen dass jedes kind sich seine
fähigkeiten und fertigkeiten entwickeln
kann die chancen bekommt und dazu gehört
auch eine angemessene besteuerung in
deutschland wird ordentlich besteuert
wir sind ja jetzt schon ehrlich gesagt
jetzt kann man ja auch europäischen
vergleich sind höchst euer land ein
grund weiner ist noch vor unter belgier
einer berlin ist ja sonst ich finde ist
es denn das ziel das ist jetzt die
letzte frage zu den tieren die möchte
ich gern ein händler stellt ist es denn
das hier ist jetzt nach belgien
überholen und der spitzenmann wäre es
wäre eine katastrophe wenn sich eine
route nehmen wir für meine partei auch
bei dieser koalition über die wir gleich
noch reden gab nämlich zu sagen es gab
keine steuer höheren walter kärnten
gegenteil wir müssen entlastung machen
ein paar machen wir einsatz bitte vor
schenkten mich zu der frage na ja das
investierte vermögen das will ich als
linker ja schon mir geht es um das große
geld vermögen also um die dagobert duck
und seinen tresor wie ist das in
wahrheit was würde denn in dem moment
passieren das geldvermögen das ist
flexibel das wandert ins ausland aber
der arme investierte und ich sag mal mit
anführungszeichen der investierte
unternehmer der jobs geschafft macht der
würde von der steuer von herrn bartsch
getroffen der müsste gegebenenfalls
verkaufen oder würde jobs abbauen
deswegen sage ich das klingt gut aber
ist weiter das gegenteil von robin hood
warum hat eigentlich die fdp ein konzept
bei der erbschaftsteuer dass durch die
bank drei prozent erhoben werden sollen
das waren also sie sie sprechen auf alte
dinge an wenn sie das wahlprogramm
reinschauen dann sehen sie dass wir bei
der erbschaftsteuer sagen es muss
vernünftige schulungsmöglichkeiten geben
weil da habe ich dann durch sich dagegen
die unterschiede nach möglichkeiten bin
ich immer dafür freie unternehmer die
unternehmer dafür nach über die ich
gerade sprach weil wir die nicht
belasten wollen wir sind ja auch für
chancengerechtigkeit befehl nach 8 und
auch für chancengerechtigkeit bei den
themen also jeder dieselbe zeit hat und
deswegen geben wir weiter zu doktor
doktor reihe an zietemann ich sage
einfach die zweitplatzierte so gerne
hätte jeder von uns gerne der
einzigen können wir sagen herr durch
die idee erzählt ja nicht umverteilen
rasch
klar also mir geht es heute um das
anders ich sagt die ampel muss weg ich
oute mich ich bin also seit 27 jahren
fdp-mitglied und vor den wahlen war es
ja so dass er gesagt hat also ihm fehlt
eigentlich die fantasie für die ampel
und er wollte jamaika haben ja gesagt
was ist denn passiert sagt erstens die
themen sind der andere geworden sie
haben jetzt ukraine krieg und das haben
wir viel mehr gemeinsamkeiten zwischen
cdu fdp und grünen und sehr wenig
gemeinsamkeiten zur spd also wenn ich
mir anschaue zb von dem
spd fraktionsvorsitzenden
dessen stellungnahme zum ukraine krieg
und vergleiche das mit alban hofreiter
von den grünen oder mit einer frau
strack zimmermann aus meiner partei das
passt einfach absolut nicht zusammen
deswegen sage ich die gemeinsamkeiten
sind größer geworden damals hat man sich
gemacht mit der cdu warum die cdu hatte
ja gar keine führung damals die wagen
völlig chaostruppe inzwischen haben die
wieder in führung haben märz und
deswegen sage ich also ich wäre dafür
machen wir jetzt das was damals nicht
geklappt hat jamaika war die haben große
herausforderungen auch gerade in bezug
auf die bundeswehr auf die außen auf die
sicherheitspolitik und da passt auf
jeden fall fdp und cdu und grüne besser
zusammen als die ampel also jetzt muss
ich und mache ich ja sehr gerne in dem
fall verteidigen das es eine ampel gibt
und ich sage mal ich kann ganz ganz viel
kritisieren auch an die im
koalitionsvertrag den die vorgelegt
haben aber eins muss man ganz ganz
sachlich sagen
gesellschaftspolitisch gibt es viele
fortschritte ob das bei frauenrechten es
wir hatten eben die übrigen thema auch
was menschen rechtliche fragen betrifft
da muss man sagen es ist ein fortschritt
zudem zu all den jahren wo die union
regiert hat zweitens ist das eine
spannende these aber eine die völlig
unrealistisch ist also da ich im
deutschen bundestag sitzen und dann auch
sehr wie die miteinander umgehen im
moment geht die union am herd ist mit
der fdp um ihren teilweise härter als
mit uns also da ist da ist also eine
illusion zu glauben dass das
zusammengeht und ich glaube im übrigen
dass auch inhaltliches mag einzelne
punkte geben dass da etwas zusammen geht
wissen die christian linder hat zwei
monate vor der wahl gesagt die
kanzlerfrage ist entschieden es geht
darum wer vizekanzler wird herr harbecke
oder ich deswegen kann man diese dinge
glaube ich nicht ganz so ernst nehmen in
der politik ich sage ganz klar diese
ampel wird entweder zerbrechen und
neuwahlen daran glaube ich nicht sondern
die werden die legislatur tapfer zu ende
machen und ich bin gespannt ob sie die
positiven dinge des koalitionsvertrags
umsetzen und bei den negativen wir
werden bescheiden die linke kleine
opposition seien aber deutlich als
erwartet wenn sie jetzt sagen dass es
unrealistisch ewigkeit zu also man darf
hier einfach mal was wünschen
hätte ich mir heute links aber ehrlich
gesagt die zeit das wünschen noch
geholfen hat dies ja leider vorbei
wünschen würde ich mir 51 fdp aber ist
meine sache haben
das ist jetzt vielleicht noch ein
bisschen realistischer als der wunsch
den ich aber im übrigen wenn er sich
gerne in deren christian lindner als
karla aber wir sehen natürlich jetzt die
hand belogen sagt gesellschaft werden
wie es fortschritte gezeigt und dann ist
es ja fast stärkste argument was man
gegen die ampel vorbringen kann da
wissen sie werden sich das an wenn sie
das so sein
also nochmal das unrealistische da gibt
es auch noch viele andere gründe
gesellschaftspolitisch habe ich das
gesagt nehmen sie die abschaffung des
119 a das ist ein fortschritt was denn
sonst nehmen sie die
einwanderungspolitik das was dort an
gedacht es ist ein fortschritt man hat
da immer noch viel zu kritisieren aber
das sind dinge die nach vorne geht ich
sage auch ganz klar ein mindestlohn von
zwölf euro im fortschritt das war jetzt
nicht unbedingt das kernthema der fdp
also es gibt dinge wo ich sage ja wohl
das ist vernünftig ich habe ganz im
übrigen auch das thema
kindergrundsicherung da habe ich nur
inzwischen große sorge dass es auch
passieren wird das ist eine
kindergrundsicherung gibt aber insgesamt
ich wie gesagt ich verteidige jetzt ich
kenne die sendung reicht nicht aus wenn
dich das kritische alles aufrufen das
ist klar aber im vergleich zu der großen
koalition und dem stillstand und die
union ist wirklich in einer lage die
haben sich so daran gewöhnt das ist nur
gut dass sie eine opposition sind besser
wäre natürlich noch einmal heran dörr
wie denn jetzt die nrw wahl steht ja vor
der tür
doktor doktor eine weile bis sich
die jamaika wird das denn nrw klappen
aktuell bei den hochrechnungen
wahrscheinlich nicht also in den
bundesländern haben wir ganz
verschiedene farben die fdp
beispielsweise ist in sachsen anhalt in
einer deutschland koalition mit
sozialdemokraten und christdemokraten
wir haben eine ampel in rheinland-pfalz
jamaika in schleswig-holstein und eine
schwarz-gelbe vielleicht klassische
koalition in düsseldorf in nrw und das
ist auch gut so auf der bundesebene
haben eine ampel koalition jetzt muss
ich ein doktortitel mann der sicher auch
gerade als fdp-mitglied geoutet hat und
das heißt dass auch fdp untereinander
diskutieren können widersprechen mir
fehlte damals im sommer so hat es
kristalliner formuliert auch ein wenig
die fantasie die ist nicht nur
entstanden sondern es auch vertrauen
gewachsen weil ich habe das mit bekommen
diese gespräche die grüne und freie
demokraten mit der union versucht haben
das war zum scheitern verurteilt
deswegen war es zu dem zeitpunkt da sind
wir uns hoffentlich einig keine optionen
eine jamaika koalition zu gehen denn der
zustand der millionen hieß führungslose
ich hatte erinnerte und jetzt sind wir
einer situation wo wir auch ein bischen
rückblicken müssen uns anschauen was ist
das erbe von 16 jahre cdu csu im bund
als regierung und da sage ich das ist
nicht so dolle bei der bundeswehr haben
wir ein erbe angetreten wo was jetzt
gerade ausbügeln müssen in der
energiepolitik herr dr dr -titel man das
korrekt gesagt dass auch gerade gesagt
in der energiepolitik sein erbe
angetreten mit krasser abhängigkeit von
russland die jetzt ein aggressor
geworden sind das heißt da sind ja
heftige fehler gemacht worden und ich
finde da kann es frische neuer koalition
das verbessern und dann komme ich
letzter satz zu den ampel projekten die
großen gegenüber 1 werden wir gleich
noch sprechen das habe ich mich heute
als thema dabei aber das thema
beispielsweise eine echte planungs
beschleunigung digitalisierung
entbürokratisierung gott wie lange
warten wir darauf unternehmer die lust
haben durchzustarten start ups die
brauchen dass das zweite thema ist das
thema bildung vernachlässigt auf der
bundesebene von der union ich habe mich
immer geärgert ich glaube dietmar
bartsch auch da hat der bund 5
milliarden für den digital praktische
schulen da sind wenige prozent 34
prozent von abgeflossen weil die union
ist nicht gebacken kriegt hat die ja die
bundesbildungsministerin zu dem
zeitpunkt stellte dass das geld bei den
schulen ankommt jetzt während der
regierungszeit der ampel und die fdp
stellt die bundesbildungsministerin ist
schon viel mehr vor ort angekommen also
dann war ganz viel
modernisierungsprojekten ich hatte nur
nachts einen guten job gemacht
fantastischen job und das sind nicht nur
gesellschaftspolitische projekte sind
auch wirtschaft politische projekte und
die war mit der union nicht zu machen
und so erneuert herr doktor doktor titel
mann ist die union noch nicht wie sie
sein müsste für regional wirklich wird
es mir auch noch sehr viel mehr eine
erneuert wünschen aber jetzt ist
natürlich auch bis unfair herrn märz
verantwortlich zu machen für die
schlechte bilanz von der frau merkel
also dass die frau merkel eine
katastrophale bilanz hat bin ich mir
sofort einig mit ihm aber jetzt zu sagen
das ist die schuld vor dem herrn merz
also dass es dann doch ein bisschen
unfair aber ich habe ja von der außen
und sicherheitspolitik gesprochen und
die glaube ich die wird immer wichtiger
egal wie lang der ukraine krieg noch
dauert ja wir haben ein riesenprogramm
vor uns die bundeswehr zu stärken und da
glaube ich da gibt es sehr viel mehr
gemeinsamkeiten zb zwischen ihrer partei
aber auch zwischen der der spd auch
zwischen der afc ja das sind ja drei
parteien die jetzt eigentlich in bezug
auf ukraine und russland ähnliche
position vertreten und da gibt es aber
umgekehrt sehr viel mehr gemeinsamkeiten
zwischen der cdu und zwischen der fdp
und auch zwischen großen teilen der
grünen und dass diese fragestellung
bundeswehr aus und sicherheitspolitik
die haben doch bei den
koalitionsverhandlungen eine ganz
untergeordnete rolle gespielt und
wahlkampf praktisch gar keine rolle
gespielt aber heute sind es die top
themen das heißt wir haben veränderte
fragestellungen und veränderte
fragestellung wiederum die müssen auch
dazu führen dass man sich veränderte
gedanken gemacht über koalition darf
sich eine steile gegenthese aus der
arterie deutschland sagen die rot-grüne
koalition unter gerhard schröder den wir
alle nicht mehr sehen wollen in der
deutschen politik heute als person aber
damals die großen sozialstaats reform
die hadsch kritisiert wir haben einen
wirtschaftlichen aufschwung für
deutschland gebracht habe ist eine
rot-grüne hat mir nie erwartet jetzt
eine ampelkoalition die bereit ist 100
milliarden euro in die bundeswehr zu
investieren also vordergründig hat dr
zählt man mögen sie herr doktor doktor
titel man mögen sie erstmal vermeintlich
recht habe man wirklich anguckt was
können regierungen leisten dann merken
wir historisch in deutschland dass
gerade die etwas ungewöhnlicheren
koalitionen die größeren reform
hinbekommen haben deswegen glaube ich
dass dieser ampel er die kraft hat weil
man es ihr nicht so zutraut nicht so
nach sagt vielleicht dass sie erschafft
die bundeswehr wirklich zu stärken als
es mit der union möglich gewesen wäre
einsatz die 100 milliarden für die
bundeswehr hätte es bald jamaika glaube
ich nicht gegeben was dürfen wir uns
denn dann davon versprechen davon daraus
dürfen wir uns versprechen dass wir ein
beweis einfach mal in den ersten 100
tagen haben wir schon und dann waren wir
mit diesem furchtbaren krieg
konfrontiert haben wir schon geschafft
dass wir energie unabhängiger von
russland geworden sind beim erdgas beim
erdöl bei der kohle haben jetzt die
möglichkeit sogar ganz uns von russland
abzukoppeln also in den wenigen tagen in
den wenigen monaten seit dem haben wir
das schon geschafft und insofern ist das
was wir jetzt machen müssen und die
anderen projekte und einzig mir ganz
persönlich am herzen die stehen im
koalitionsvertrag wir müssen das
aufstiegsversprechen der sozialen
marktwirtschaft erneut in deutschland
wer an klotz wer lust hat zu arbeiten
der eine tolle ausbildung hat weil er
richtig geackert hat als junger mensch
der muster vor auch was haben der muss
sich was aufbauen können dieses
aufstiegsversprechen ist unter der union
verloren gegangen und das wird die ampel
jetzt nach vorne bringen die
entscheidende frage ist ja dass man auch
die ampel dann die taten messen sollte
ich habe nicht der aktions vertrag
gesprochen und habe das was zu loben ist
auch gelobt ich nehme jetzt mal das
thema energiepolitik raus also nun kann
man ja das begeistert aufnehmen das
jetzt mit katar und anderen ländern dort
gespräche laufen ich kann nur sagen ich
war dabei schon im deutschen bundestag
dass nach den furchtbaren attentaten in
new york gesagt wurde von denen müssen
wir unabhängig werden und da ist viel
raus gegangen also von einem despoten
zum nächsten das eigentliche ist doch
dass energiewende was alle sagen
erneuerbarer energien ausbaue reduktion
usw da warte ich noch die abhängigkeit
von russland zu reduzieren also jetzt
nämlich mal russland weg wir nehmen das
mal die kohle also in deutschland sind
wir so unendlich stolz dass wir aus der
steinkohle ausgestiegen sind das ist ja
auch in ordnung nur für importieren
steinkohle jetzt irgendwie aus kolumbien
wo die kohle leute sagen dann mit stadt
liegt immer noch eine leiche auf dem
schiff also das sagt nicht ich er hätte
es doch irgend etwas schräg wir machen
wir wir müssen doch wir müssen doch wenn
wir das wollen und ich weiß dass das
keine leichte aufgabe ist aber bitte
dann eine perspektive auf machen die
dann wirklich dazu führt dass das
disputen frei ist und das ist ein
riesenproblem und ich will noch einen
satz sagen also wirklich widersprechen
der these dass wir in der russland
politik eine ähnliche position haben wir
140 08 das stimmt überhaupt also ist
eine glatte lüge
ist gleich direkten der zug und ich bin
sehr gespannt ob fdp und die linke auch
nach der werbung beim thema russland so
auf kuschelkurs sind es ja ganz neu
heute abend hier bist ja ich musste
also da kann ich dann ein lauter
brauchen und nicht ernst nehmen als
sogenannten experten
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren bei personal 855 meinungen jeder
von uns hat ein thema mitgebracht wird
ärgert freut oder schockiert
[Musik]
so nicht erwartet hätten das auge ist
aber niemand von den politischen
parteien traut sich zu sagen ja das
wollen wir einfach nur freiheit diese
grün-roten der damen führen hochtrabende
debatten über die rettung des weltklimas
und um die füße russland die ratten das
thema ist viel zu wichtig um es nur
derart zu überlassen lasst den leuten
noch mal den spaß wir sehen da etwas was
eigentlich vertrag ist in der politik
bei den journalisten deren job ist es
doch gerade abweichende meinungen zu
finden und sie sollen den doch auch
richtig durch
vielleicht einmal kurz einsatz bleiben
wir ganz nennen doch das sind übliche
andrack träger aus und ist in bewegung
bringen ich habe meinen beifall immer
eine sache immer bekommen er kümmert
sich darum niemand dass israel den man
muss da ganz kleinlich auch darüber
sprechen das ist einfach nicht fair für
mich richtig wohl ist die aufgabe von
journalismus einfach die verlautbarungen
der politik zu hinterfragen
[Musik]
also willkommen zurück liebe zuschauer
und wir möchten jetzt direkt zum bild
vize und ja auch viele nachahmer
schalten er hält sich mittlerweile im
osten der ukraine auf und er hat uns
heute auch an meiner stelle eine these
mitgebracht die er mit der runde
diskutieren möchte paul
wo bist du gerade und was ist deine
kaminabend
janina wir sind mittlerweile im donbass
angekommen in konstantinov gar einer
kleinen stadt und der wir damals so kann
man sagen am 23 februar 24 februar
aufgebrochen sind nach kiew auch damals
haben wir von hier geschaltet für
viertel nach acht und gehört ist
vielleicht im hintergrund andauernder
raketenalarm hier im donbass in der
nacht das ist ein bisschen geisterhaft
kann man fast sagen fast alle lichter
aus viele menschen sind von ihr längst
geflohen und um uns herum ungefähr 10 15
20 kilometer entfernt da ist die
frontlinie momentan du hörst den
raketenalarm im hintergrund und das
bringt mich auch zu meiner these ich
glaube dass das was deutschland tut was
waffenlieferungen angeht noch nicht
ausreicht wir brauchen noch viel härtere
wirtschaftliche sanktionen und zwar
sofort ich glaube dass der krieg und
dass der druck auf putin nur dann
zunimmt wenn es wirklich ein umfassendes
embargo gibt also wenn es nicht nur ein
öl-embargo gibt sondern wenn es auch ein
gas embargo gibt putin versucht ja
bereits und zu erpressen er versucht zu
drohen er hat polen und bulgarien
bereits angekündigt dass man kein gas
mehr liefern werde weil die beiden
länder nicht in rubel zahlen wollten wie
ich finde sollte europa durchgreifen das
wird hart das wird hart natürlich das
wird wirtschaftskraft und kosten aber am
ende glaube ich braucht es diesen druck
um hier in der ukraine wirklich eine
veränderung herbeizuführen deswegen
plädiere ich dafür öl und gas boykott
sofort wir sollten uns nicht länger von
wladimir putin erpressen lassen
paul ich sehe das ja ganz genau so wie
du dass man da harte sanktionen treffen
muss nur was ich mich frage ist was ist
denn dann die lösung auch für die bürger
weil diejenigen sind ja die die das am
ende auch zu spüren bekommen vor allem
und das hat er dann auch schon vorhin
gesagt die gering und mittelständischen
verdiener
wenn das die frage an mich war also ich
denke das ist natürlich ein
sozialausgleich braucht ich glaube dass
deutschland diesen auch leisten kann das
problem wenn ich die bundesregierung
richtig verstehe warum man das sozusagen
argumentiert und da gibt es sehr
unterschiedliche wirtschaftliche
analysen auch was das ganze am ende
bedeuten würde ist dass man sorge hat
dass der industriestandort deutschland
geschwächt würde das ist sicherlich so
die frage ist wie immens und wenn man
sich anschaut was der preis ist noch
einmal hier diesem moment wir haben auch
gerade wieder schüsse gehört von weitem
dieser ort hier wo ich gerade stehe das
ist ein klares ziel auch von wladimir
putin r will diesen ganzen don was sich
einverleiben bis zum 9 das ist eines der
wichtigen daten und ich glaube dass wir
jetzt noch viel mehr härte brauchen auch
überraschen der härte denn das ist etwas
mit dem laden putin nicht rechnet würde
das die europäische union vereint gehe
ein steht und sagt wir machen den
boykott jetzt wir hören uns nicht länger
an wie du unser pressen witz und
natürlich braucht es dann einen sozialen
ausgleich herr bartsch sind sie auch für
das umfassende öl- und gas-embargo was
bei vanessa nach vorgeschlagen hat also
ein solches ich weiß gar nicht wie paul
ronzheimer zu der these kommt dass das
dazu führen würde dass putin dann auf
einmal anders agieren würde ist eine
sehr gewagte these ich sehe das
wahnsinnige dilemma in dem wir uns
befinden deutschland bezieht weiterhin
gas aus der ukraine bezahlt dass auch
pünktlich das ist für niemanden hier in
irgendeiner weise etwa eine angenehme
situation
aber wir müssen natürlich auch wissen
also soweit das kann man lade mir putin
schon zutrauen dass das sehr wohl
eingepreist wäre natürlich wenn das
plötzlich ein boykott geben würde das
würde so verheerende auswirkungen haben
in unserem land dass genau das was sein
ziel ist nämlich spalt und gesellschaft
spaltung des westens das würde passieren
und deswegen sage ich da finde ich
richtig dass man damit sensibel umgeht
und dass man vor allen dingen wenn denn
gemeinsam mit europäischen partnern
agiert also und die der letzte punkt ist
die energiefrage das ist eine wo
deutschland das schaf wird sich
loszulösen von russland aber es gibt
natürlich andere rohstoffe die viel
problematischer sind wo es auch normal
jetzt weitergeht also ich sag mal ganz
nebenbei die gaslieferungen gehen im
übrigen durch die ukraine und die
ukraine bekommt durchleitungsgebühren
weiterhin von russland das läuft weiter
und ich sage mal ein glück das ist
weiter läuft manchmal tun wir so also es
ist doch auch bei anderen dingen so als
wenn sagen die ukraine wird halt gerade
russland fast schon asche zu legen
sollte keine also und damit kein
missverständnis gibt es ein furchtbarer
verheerender erfolgreiches wieder krieg
der durch nichts zu rechtfertigen ist da
haben wir eine position am tisch also
null null toleranz 0 wirklich und er
muss schnellstmöglich beendet werden die
frage ist nur wird er denn schneller
beendet wird er schneller beendet wenn
wir wirklich ein gas boykott ein öl
boykott ganz schnell umsetzen würden
oder wie werden die fälle die
verwerfungen der deutschen industrie in
anderen industrie industrieländern das
muss man abwägen ich kann das gar nicht
abschließend einschätzen aber egal da
schaue ich dann wirklich auf
bundesregierung und andere die dort
sagen ja wir wollen reduzierung ja ich
kann mir auch vorstellen dass man sagt
wir machen das prozentual und vielleicht
auch schneller das ist nicht der punkt
aber das wird dieses problem nicht löst
das ist ähnlich wie mit den
waffenlieferungen ich glaube ihm nicht
einmal ganz kurz zu paul ronzheimer er
kann sich jetzt einschalten aber weil
sie die frage gestellt haben wie er
überhaupt auf diese these kommt das ist
das notwendig sind wir ja genau die
frage will ich dann gerne mal an ihn
aufstellen gelobt dass er das auch
erklären kann wie er zu der these com
paul
also ich habe nicht gesagt dass es damit
sofort zu ende wäre ich habe gesagt dass
das massiven druck und überraschenden
druck auf vladimir putin
geben würde und wenn wir uns anschauen
die summen die seit beginn des krieges
überwiesen wurden nach russland die sind
einfach immens und am ende wird
natürlich damit die kriegsmaschinerie
finanziert wenn ich etwas zu hören dann
denke ich natürlich auch sehr viel daran
dass die linkspartei in den vergangenen
jahren über russland gesagt hat wladimir
putin wie viele herr bartsch nicht
selbst aber andere aus seiner partei mit
wladimir putin
ja sehr nett umgegangen sind immer
wieder dafür geworben haben dass man
doch verständnis haben müsse für die
russischen position verständnis auf für
wladimir putin dass er doch recht habe
dass die nato doch näher gekommen ist
und wenn dann jemand aus der linkspartei
die dinge in frage stellt und sagt na ja
aber weiß man denn was dann passiert
dann sage ich nur sie lagen mit allem
was sie über wladimir putin gesagt haben
in den letzten zwei jahrzehnten falsch
also darf ich ausdrücklich widersprechen
wladimir putin haben besucht kann ich
ihn aufzählen edmund stoiber früher
schon franz josef strauß sigmar gabriel
also kann ich ihn auf zelda war von der
linken nie jemand dabei ich habe
wladimir putin noch nie gesehen
allerdings glaube ich dass ich vom land
etwas verstehe weil ich da auch mal drei
jahre nach esperanto gemacht habe ja ich
habe falsch gelegen das ist wahr dass da
stimme ich ausdrücklich zu nur dass
jetzt zur begründung zu machen deswegen
ist richtig dass man die gaslieferungen
und auch die öllieferungen sofort
einstellt das wiederum eine sehr gewagte
these weil das eine begründet dass
andere wahrhaftig nicht ich sage ich
sage klar ja in putin haben sich viele
getäuscht ich zähle dazu ich habe das
nicht für möglich gehalten weil in
meinem seminar waren ukraine waren
russen sie haben miteinander keine
konflikte gehabt und das habe ich für
nicht möglich angesehen jetzt sehen wir
diesen verheerenden krieg und ich sage
noch mal ich hab das mehrfach gesagt
putin ist ein kriegsverbrecher und was
alles tun dass der krieg beendet wird
aber ich teile die auffassung
ausdrücklich nicht dass ein sofortiges
ball kommt und nebenbei wird das auch
nicht kommen das stadtfest war den krieg
verkürzen würde es könnte sogar zu
gegenteiligen reaktionen führen denn es
ist kein zufall dass sowohl die ukraine
als auch russland als auch deutschland
sich an das bisherige prozedere hält das
ist so und da gibt es gründe für kenny
will kann die debatte jetzt leider
aufgrund der zeit deswegen würde ich
sagen paul de gehört das schlusswort zu
deiner these und leider konnte die
debatte nicht ganz öffnen weil sie beide
sehr miteinander es war auch gut so ist
war sehr spannend so zu einem teil es
ist ein letzter punkt
mein letzter punkt ist das wenn man
nicht für das gas und öl boykott ist
dass man doch dringt argumente und
lösungen auf den tisch bringen sollte
was aus der sicht der linken oder aus
der sicht von anderen parteien dazu
führt dass dieses geräusch im donbass
und nicht nur das sondern die
bombardierung die auslöschung von frauen
und kindern die ermordung von menschen
in mario pohl in diesen minuten die
ausgehungert werden dort im stahlwerk
dass das endlich ein ende
nur der eine satz hier paul ronzheimer
wenn ich das wüsste würde ich das sofort
mitteilen aber leider hat im moment
niemand die lösung wir ringen auch im
deutschen bundestag an vielen stellen
genau darum und in einem sind wir uns
glaube ich jedenfalls weitgehend den
deutschen bundestag einig der krieg muss
zu ende sein und wir müssen alles in
diese richtung tun und ich möchte dass
die militärische schlagseite nicht zu
groß wird sondern dass ich zum beispiel
hoffnung setze wenn morgen herr görisch
nach erfährt nachdem er bei putin war
ich wünsche haben wir als diplomatisch
da muss ich wirklich wirklich wünsche
mir ja bei mir ja das letzte wort gelten
sollte in dieser debatte ok ok und ich
sage ja nicht dass gesagt und wenn sie
und wenn sie sagen dass militärische
sollte nicht überhand gewinnen dann muss
ich mich wirklich fragen wo sie
hinschauen denn wenn sie sehen was
russland in diesen minuten wo wir
sprechen in mariupol macht wie die
menschen dort ermordet werden dann tut
putin alles militärische was in seiner
macht steht und diese debatte finde ich
sorry zu sehen nur noch absurd weil
vielen dank für deine worte und auch
obwohl jetzt schon seit drei monaten
scheint es muss ich sagen dass ich jedes
mal gänsehaut habe wenn du darüber rede
ist und man die sie reden hört und es
ist furchtbar und wir hoffen dass der
krieg bald endet und jetzt machen wir
weiter schwer aber wir probieren jetzt
im übergang zum thema von christian dior
danke paul
ja vielen dank ich habe ein thema
mitgebracht was mir am herzen nicht
deutschland ist eines der ältesten
länder der welt das ist erstmal keine
schlechte nachricht denn menschen werden
gesünder älter in deutschland das eine
gute nachricht großer zivilisatorischer
schritt gleichzeitig sage ich wir werden
aus eigener bevölkerung den wohlstand
den wir heute haben heute haben die
arbeitskräfte die wir heute in
deutschland haben nicht aufrechterhalten
können deswegen meine these deutschland
muss endlich ein modernes
einwanderungsland werden in der
vergangenheit sind sehr viele fehler
gemacht worden menschen sind
eingewandert in die sozialen
sicherungssysteme das war falsch wir
müssen den arbeitsmarkt endlich breit
öffnen es gibt demografen die sich damit
wissenschaftlich beschäftigen die haben
vor einigen jahren mal ausgerechnet dass
jede familie in deutschland sieben
kinder bekommen müsste um diese so
genannte demografische lücke zu
schließen das heißt meine these modernes
einwanderungsland für deutschland das
ist uns auch ein projekt im angriff
vertrag und ich sage an der stelle auch
einrichtung von der dr dr -titel man die
union hat in den letzten 16 jahren hier
nichts gemacht das ist ihr ist
touristisch historisches versagen und
deswegen wird die ampel liefern
ja
es stimme ich zu weil wir müssen beim
thema zuwanderung mehr differenzieren
das geschieht oft nicht in der
diskussion ist mal ganz holzschnittartig
wir brauchen viel viel mehr zuwanderung
von qualifizierten fachkräften und wir
brauchen viel viel weniger zuwanderung
in die sozialsysteme bisher ist es
umgekehrt und das hat einen ganz
einfachen grund weil die zuwanderung in
die sozialsysteme ist relativ einfach du
gehst dann die grenze sagt das wort asyl
und dem moment bist du erst mal im
verfahren drin was mehrere jahre dauert
und egal wie es ausgeht wo auch die
wahrscheinlichkeit also bleiben kannst
relativ hoch ist während wenn du als
fachkraft zu wandern bist dann hast du
unglaubliche bürokratische hürden
abgesehen davon hatten auch folge eines
der länder mit den höchsten steuersätzen
soll ja was auch nicht unbedingt
attraktiv die zuwanderung dann auch noch
eine schwere sprache dazu also wir haben
sowieso ganz viele hürden und dann noch
die zusätzliche beratung hört also da
müssen wir unbedingt was dagegen tun und
es gehängt aber auch beides zusammen ja
wir müssen andererseits und das finde
ich nicht gut bei der ampel auch ganz
deutlich wirklich mal diese zuwanderung
in die sozialsysteme
reduzieren weil das auch am ende dazu
führt dass die akzeptanz von zuwanderung
von fachkräften sinkt weil die meisten
menschen oder ich sage nicht die meisten
viele menschen leider nicht zu
differenzieren die sagen dann einfach
acht zuwanderer billig nicht mehr her
und deswegen sage ich wir müssen
tatsächlich das bei dem ein sagen ja
brauchen wir unbedingt bei dem anderen
ein und bei dem ein glaube ich auch
gerne dass die ampel jetzt was machen
wird mehr zuwanderung von fachkräften
aber bei dem anderen thema glauben sie
mir einst dass sie mit den grünen und
mit unserer innenministerin wie wir sie
jetzt haben eine begrenzung der zahl
systeme hinbekommen also da bin ich ja
sehr sehr skeptisch
dann müssen wir bin ich darf die dinge
differenzieren humanitäre flüchtlings
migration asyl das ist auch
rechtsstaatlich gebotenen sogar meiner
sicht gerade jetzt in der sonderzone die
wir gerade auch darin wieder spricht
keiner aber sie haben recht die
situation 215 war ja eine solche die
deutschland ja auch
gesellschaftspolitisch fast auseinander
gerissen hat das darf nicht passieren
aber der druck natürlich auf die
einwanderung in die sozialen
sicherungssysteme ist so groß weil das
andere so versperrt ist das heißt du
nahe dass andere öffnen na klar viele
menschen haben lust durchzustarten viele
menschen von denen die kommen die
zurzeit über das asylsystem das
flüchtlings system kommen die wären viel
besser aufgehoben als reguläre
einwanderer und an einem punkt möchte
ich herrn dr dr -titel man widersprechen
nämlich es geht nicht nur um hoch
höchstqualifizierte und promovierte
menschen sondern es geht um die ganz
ganz breite masse es fehlt überall im
handwerk 14 hunderttausende von
arbeitskraft allein in deutschland
fehlen glaube ich 70.000 lkw-fahrer dh
diese these es geht nur um spitzen
qualifizierte das ist ausdruck lang war
mein weg 230.000 handwerk vielen dank
für den hinweis also es ist dramatisch
der chef der bundesagentur für arbeit
spricht von einer nettozuwanderung von
400.000 die wir brauchen jetzt muss man
auch sagen warum um unseren wohlstand zu
erhalten damit die renten stabil bleiben
das hat ja alles einen grund also die
müssen ist so machen ich würde
zusammenfassen die moderne
einwanderungsländer kanada australien
neuseeland die machen das sehr klug seit
vielen jahrzehnten wir haben es noch
viel nötiger und ja das ist ein auftrag
deswegen macht sich die ampel da auf den
weg also wenn ich da weniger bemerkung
zu machen möchte erstens finde ich es
darf überhaupt kein zweifel sein dass in
deutschland das asylrecht gilt und dass
wir hier eine verantwortung eine frage
das ist total wichtig weil manchmal wird
als erstes gesagt was wir alles nicht
dürfen sondern aber dieser fakt steht
und wir unterscheiden dort auch nicht
nach flüchtlingen aus syrien oder aus
schwarzafrika wenn es um asylrecht geht
oder aus der ukraine
da gibt es keine unterschiede es gilt
die rechtslage ist für alle gleich das
muss man immer einmal sagen zweiter ich
bin sehr dafür bin sehr dafür dass wir
erst mal feststellen wir sind ein
einwanderungsland und dass wir dort
deutlich moderner werden schneller
werden das war mal in der großen
koalition der letzten legislatur das
stand im koalitionsvertrag dass die
verfahren verkürzt werden sollen ist das
laub auf drei monate ja und was ist die
realität ich weiß 15 usw es ist extrem
lange wir müssen dort deutlich schneller
werden ich wünsche mir ein modernes
einwanderungsgesetz da haben wir
erhebliche differenz und dann wie es
konkret machen vermutlich aber das ist
weiter gar nicht schlimm wir müssen
endlich grundlagen schaffen bei uns auch
in meiner partei gab es dann eine breite
diskussion dazu wird auch durchaus
unterschiedlich gesehen das finde ich
nicht tragisch aber endlich dort eine
regelung war lange zeit war er die these
wir brauchen kein einwanderungsgesetz
das war die these im bundestag die
mehrheitsfähig war und diese these die
ist einfach nicht stimmig wir müssen die
vielen dinge die es bereits gibt
zusammenfassen und da hoffe ich dass die
ampel dann wirklich vorliegt handelt und
das dann auch so entsprechend das werden
wir sicherlich ganz kontrovers
diskutieren aber dass dann die grundlage
da ist weil das ist glaube ich dringend
notwendig valentina empfindest du
deutschland jetzt schon als modernes
einwanderungsland oder haben wir da noch
einen beiden weg zu gehen meine
persönliche einschätzung ist dass wir
noch einen sehr weiten weg zu gehen
haben ich glaube da sind wir uns ja sehr
ähnlich nina und ich sind junge frauen
die machen wollen die das
leistungsprinzip fördern ich habe das
gefühl dass wir uns aktuell auf wo ich
hab keinen migrationshintergrund ich
schon und ich komme aus einer
gastronomie familie also ich bin die
erste in meiner familie die studiert hat
worauf ich sehr stolz bin merke aber
dass es durchaus unterschiede gibt und
dass es fakt und das spüren wir auch
tagtäglich aus welcher familie man kommt
oder nicht das ist einfach so dass kann
man den menschen auch gar nicht übel
nehmen sondern es ist einfach ein
unterschied wenn ich in der familie
aufwachsen die gewisse kontakte hat die
ein gewisses netzwerk hat die gewisse
erfahrungswerte im berufsleben hat oder
es ist ein unterschied ob ich aus einer
gastronomie familie komme die sehr
einfach lebt und das schätze ich auch
sehr und da soll man auch nie vergessen
wo man herkommt dennoch das gibt einem
werte mit die andere so vielleicht nicht
mitbekommen aber es ist dennoch ein
unterschied weil man viel weiter hinten
anfängt als beispielsweise kinder einer
akademikerfamilie und ich finde wir
müssen da irgendwie eine
gleichberechtigung schaffen aber wir
müssen vorsichtig sein weil in diesen
ganzen gleichberechtigungs debatten
leider entwickeln wir uns dann in eine
richtung die dann wiederum auch
diskriminierung oder benachteiligung
genau für die andere seite schweiz war
ein schönes schlusswort die politik hat
viel zu tun selten habe ich eine runde
weniger gerne ab moderiert und bis
morgen abend tschüss
[Musik]